thank you
[Music]
I don't know if you guys heard about
this but a Canadian firm had announced
that it received a license to legally
make and sell cocaine
whoa medically well here's the thing it
made this announcement everybody went
crazy news reports are still saying oh
yeah this company can make and sell
cocaine the stock of that company went
up 400 percent
um is it are they called four Locos
morphine basically like legal yeah yeah
morphine is heroin or whatever and yeah
yeah it is but what happened is if we
had done this new story like three days
ago or something we wouldn't have heard
this part the Prime Minister came out to
correct the issue Trudeau yeah and he's
like no no no no it's not you don't have
a permit to sell to the public what they
can do is they can make and man they can
manufacture it to sell to other licensed
dealers that are selling for medical or
scientific purpose oh okay what's a
medical cocaine like uh well it's
technically cocaine but it's not like in
Like Cocaine Street form it's more like
cocaine medical form like it's just like
in a liquid where you can just like but
what do you like is it like numbing no I
thought I thought to make medicine yeah
isn't it called um
or no I don't know there's a there's a
there's a more medical name coding is
sizzurp yeah let's treat me look at it
is a [__] fun time but when it's not
snorted it's also used like as a
painkiller and [__] like that it can be
it's not always the first choice of
painkiller yeah but or they added an IV
[__] really but there's but there's two
companies that are basically everybody
was raving and hollering about this I
want a new permit but it's like that
company as well sounds like a loophole
only sell it to dealers uh for
scientific women it's a loophole yeah
yeah for sure I was like if people are
celebrating it's because they know they
can do something different yeah they got
options well Trudeau was saying that if
anything happens where they continue to
mistreat the public about their permit
then they're going to revoke it oh
that's true because he's like stop
making people think that they can just
start buying cocaine from you guys how
would you use medical cocaine though
like if I was hurt I wouldn't want to be
I want to feel like oh I just want to
relax maybe you feel like I'm a [__]
broken leg
I'm guessing once they like you know mix
it with different things it's not like
it's gonna give you an up and maybe give
you a numb right um painkillers [__] you
up it's like it's like when you uh I
wouldn't know this but allegedly if you
like snow core can't uh snort cocaine
right you you do get that up but if
you're taking you rub it on your gums it
like numbs your gums but it doesn't make
you more up you know what I'm saying
people do that I've never taken cocaine
so maybe that's why I don't know what a
good purpose we should try wait that's
why people do that
you've seen people do that right they'll
take the cocaine after they're done
smoking dog
and it [__] just numbs the [__] out
of your gums dude I remember the first
time I saw it so it's a tingly sensation
the first time I saw someone do cocaine
like in front of me at like a party was
one of the wildest Things ever because
they literally do it like out of the
movies and they and they oh and you're
like whoa that's that's not the big
stuff because that's you know his
fingernails like a little bump but it's
like when I walk into a bathroom the
first they do a line yeah and you got
just long ass lines and stuff with
hundred dollar bills off of mirrors well
they do it five more times that's when
you're like oh that adds up
sounds like you've never been a Latino
party dude I saw that [__] a [__]
five years old dude they'll be telling
like intense like like normal stories
yeah go back what had a drama the other
day I went to work and then I gotta and
uh
[__] I was thinking with some
Guatemalans actually yeah they're
talking about normal Day stuff talking
about how to fix a car you put the
transmission first but when you get the
things
some of the hobbies that told me that
they work at like their welders and they
do overnight stuff oh yeah they need it
they do it to stay up at roofers or the
cross-country truck drivers you gotta
stay up and [__] how come they don't do
math it's a blue collar well there's
something they do they do it's like
Adderall though I would say just just
just drink some coffee
to me with drugs it's like the reason
why I don't do drugs is because I know I
think well being around it as a kid like
I know what's gonna happen to you oh
yeah and I don't want that you see the
like I just see like yo like the crazy
guy in [__] Circle K just like
talking himself did this yeah so I don't
want to do this like that's it
well you need to get curious like what
world is he seen no
I do think I do think it's when people
are abusing such a good question I see
what you're saying you have a good point
I like the way your brain works but I I
was always like a control freak like I I
like to be in control when I'm not in
control of my body I don't like that
feeling what does the opposite mean like
a out of control freak for me impulsive
yeah just kind of like a guy who just
goes with The Escapist I can't go with
the flow you're self-aware so you know
how to do that you know and that way uh
you would run into a problem if you like
you know started using whereas other
people who are self-aware and maybe uh
don't have that control freak nature I
do think that there's like a more so
psycho psychedelics versus like [__]
anything that's crazy like that you know
what I mean to like explore those
Curiosities and discover and dive deeper
and stuff because if you don't abuse it
and use it once sometimes people [__]
get their life changed in like positive
ways I do think psychedelics are a
little bit different than like cocaine
and heroin worse but it is all clumped
in the same conversation of drugs for
the people that don't understand have
you guys have you guys tried
psychedelics yeah it's pretty sweet I
feel like for sure you tried that
I feel like cocaine I I tried I would
never do it just because I know that I
probably would never stop oh yeah dude
and that's the thing with like any hard
drug like I feel like once I open that
floodgates like that's what that's why I
never tried it I did a bunch of the
drugs too I wanted to but I couldn't get
it I already have an addictive
personality so I know if I if I have
addictive personally like something
that's highly addictive I'm [__] yeah
there's actually a time where I was like
starting to kind of party a lot and like
that that's one like I really got
exposed to cocaine I started doing it
like a lot right
um and then there was one night and it
was like I went back to my parents house
after [__] just raging and just doing
hella Coke and I wake up that next
morning at my parents house in my old
bed and I just got like blood from my
nose like oh yeah dude all over the
pillow sheets and stuff and that was
like my first wake-up call to be like
get out of this and I had to I kind of
had to like go some of those friends for
that period of time to get away from it
not for that's probably a good strategy
that's uh yeah that would be it for me
yeah that's it remember smoked weed and
I felt like my heart was like too fat
and that was it I was like yeah I don't
want to do this yeah I'm freaking the
[__] out I'm good I don't want to be
freaked out because that's when people
do Coke like when they party right is
like just to kind of keep the party
going to stay up and it's like you know
it gets it gets Social sometimes too
right like you know you're just saying
you want to do a bump and then you know
everybody goes to the bathroom you start
doing things and next thing you know
everybody's mad lit you know what I mean
you could drink more too you think that
you're a gangster and you can drink way
more and it's it's stupid but it's cool
that's what they're thinking yeah but
what we're seeing is like a yeah dude
here look are you all right
that's why everybody wants everyone on
it dude you got that face down really
good I've been around these
[__] they're just talking like
yeah
[Laughter]
there's one dude I knew that did a bunch
of coke and then like when he whenever
he's on coke I always know because he's
always like talking like this at the
side of it their job just kind of like
an upper lip thing and I was like a
Ninja Turtles figure and he always and
he always talks like the like he's like
come here
and he talks on the side of his mouth
I'm part of your recognition okay right
now and he gets really chatty he starts
talking about it yeah my friend who used
to get chatty and he's just looking that
was a scary sight to see when I remember
I remember I went in his room because we
were like in his house I was gonna ask
for a condom because I had a girl
open the door and he was just like going
in and his eyes and just facing I was
like I remember thinking like that's so
dark like you're by yourself it's four
in the morning oh there's girls out here
and you're in your room right now
that's dark that's when I was like I
don't want to be that way did you get
that condom though condo was God and uh
you know what I mean
[Laughter]
my ex had a she did so much she did so
much coke that she had a hole in her
nose whoa I heard about people she did
it so much that it's on the inside and
then and she told me like prior to me
like finding out I'm like how am I gonna
find out I'm not gonna look he's gonna
be like I see
but the reason the reason she told me is
that when she sleeps it whistles
have you ever seen that but like some
people do it so much that they have a
whistle when they breathe have they ever
switch nostrils I mean I don't know if
it matters they just like does she sleep
like a cartoon where she goes
I mean yeah yeah
thank you